So I haven't really told anybody this,
but I have gotten. Well,
I've told one person. I have gotten really into jewelry making lately.
It's become a new ADHD hyperfixation project,
and it's been really fun. I've made some really cute pieces.
I can post some if you want.
I'm not, like,
selling them or anything. They're just for me,
because I'm a jewelry girl.
But today, something really cool happened.
So I have this necklace I wear all the time,
and the not cool part is that it broke. Right?
And typically, you know,
I'm a bit of, like,
I'm a bit of a consumer. Like,
I probably would have just ordered a new one,
because I have these new, fun,
crafty skills.
I know that it's just missing one of these jump ring things.
And I now have my little pliers and some jump rings.
They're not exactly the same,
but I'm gonna see if it can do the trick,
and it'll save me a whole another necklace.
So kind of sharing my little win here.
So jump rings are just like that.
They look like little rings.
You just use two pliers to kind of open it up,
and then I'm gonna connect these two pieces. Now it's fixed.